hi I'm Eric vos and Rick and Morty's
episode the ABCs of Beth had one of the
most open-ended and mysterious endings
ever with Rick hippy and Beth the
opportunity to leave her mundane life
behind in the hands of a clone and as
much as I hate to admit it ABC's The
Bachelor can make a clone of you a
perfect instance of you with all your
memories an exact copy in every way and
a love and provide for the kids do your
job and consume broadcast network
reality TV on the same allegedly ironic
level as you you could be gone a day a
week or the rest of your life with zero
consequences now we never officially see
Beth's decision but the final scene the
episode definitely showed a different
more unwound version of bet than we've
seen all season what would we do without
you I love you dad so that leaves us
with this question is Beth a clone it's
clear that the writers intended on this
question remaining open ended and
unanswered that's kind of what the
series Rick and Morty is all about based
on the number of times they pulled this
kind of move in the past remember in
season ones Rick potion number nine Rick
and Morty left their old reality in the
c-137 dimension behind swap in into this
new one and the Morty's mined blowers
episode confirm that that kind of
reality swap has happened more than once
you know I said we can only do that a
couple of times
we're over here so these characters are
Hardy feel alienated from the realities
they live in but on top of that the
season 3 premiere shows Rick swapping
his consciousness into at least three
new Rick host bodies then later in rest
and relaxation he spawned a new body out
of toxic Rick combine all of that with
the existence of replacement Android
Morty introduced in Rick Nancy in the
stone and the ending of season two's
morning night run when they picked up
Jerry from day care without the right
ticket meaning they could have had the
wrong Jerry from a different dimension
this whole time do you have 5 1 to 6 I'm
not sure Morty that's a Blitzen [ __ ]
ticket what way to go Morty yeah
whatever
wait what the point is all of these
characters could be false replacements
of each other and no member of this
family is where they should be that's
the point of the show nobody belongs
anywhere but getting back to Beth in
this episode where it kind of tells us
earlier on because you're oh god yes I'm
one of infinite best with infinite
fathers and infinite universes it's
called a hug dad it won't kill you yeah
don't be so sure so yes Rick could just
be referring to
the past reality swapping an alienation
that I talked about earlier but
something about this feels like Rick and
Beth have had this conversation before
this dynamic definitely felt like a
subtle homage to the showest world with
hosts learning that they aren't alive
they're just hollow shells of humanity
who get reset whenever they become too
self-aware we've had this conversation
before so yeah I think not only is Beth
at the end of this episode a clone
I think past versions we've seen a bet
have been clones - Rick just sounds so
bored as he explains to Beth how the
cloning and replacing would work as if
this is a routine conversation he's had
with every iteration of his daughter
also notice what words he says to Beth
here the moment you decided to come back
I flip the switch and the clones job is
done
it feels no pain regrets nothing and has
zero chance of going Blade Runner that's
interesting that Rick brings up Blade
Runner that movie famously ended with
one of the most open-ended mysteries
that has had fans debating for decades
is Harrison Ford's Deckard actually a
replicant an AI imposter blade runner's
director Ridley Scott left just enough
clues in his cut of the film for one to
conclude that Deckard is indeed a
replicant and his memories were actually
implanted in his mind but a clearer firm
answer would go against what the film is
all about it's a test to prove humanity
and that question of what exactly makes
us human is what drives both Blade
Runner and Rick and Morty both
ultimately reached the same conclusion
what does it matter if we can't tell the
difference let me know what you think
about this theory in the comments below
or tweet me directly at EA boss or
follow the new rock stars at new
rockstars for updates on our videos and
be sure to check out my full episode
breakdown as well like and share this
video and subscribe to new rock stars
for all of our Rick and Morty theory and
analysis and if you really like us you
can contribute to us on patreon thank
you for watching bye